all right it's 5 36. so the holiday rush
is here as you may have noticed and so
is the rush to get tested for covet 19
to keep everyone
safe several places are offering free
testing today all across the valley
hector mejia live this morning near mlk
and lake mead boulevard with the details
hi hector good morning
hey there alex good morning and although
experts recommend staying home many are
still choosing to get tested before the
festivities this week
a negative test means a chance to
connect with family members
even as coronavirus cases climb here
locally and there are a few
options offering free testing here in
the valley
this is from the health district's
website we are at doolittle senior
center near
mlk and lake mead where we're live this
morning over at cashman center an
appointment is
highly encouraged plus inside the stan
fulton building at unlv
and at the southern nevada health
district and state health leaders
predict a surge on top of a surge as
covet 19 spreads
over christmas and new year's they said
hospitals are ready for an influx of
cases heading into the new year
capacity though has always been a
concern all year long
a quick update on where things stand
right now this morning the state's
website that tracks testing has the
positivity rate
at 19.7 percent that's for testing
conducted over the last 14 days and i
actually got tested myself here
at this facility last week and got my
results within a day and a half but with
so many people rushing to get tested
that could slow down results and it
could take several days for you
to know your status reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now